our next talk is by andre rubizono
andre is an assistant professor at yale
university he was a pg student here in
berkeley and the postdocs in madison and
georgia tech he has done
a lot of very very interesting work and
optimization and sampling and the
combination of the two and uh i believe
this talk will be in that spirit
and uh he gives us great talks and also
does very interesting work so i'm
excited for this one i'm excited for all
the talks but
this one is closest to what i do
okay please
thank you uh thank you elena um hi
everyone um thank you for telling this
thought my name is andrew pisono i'm at
yale university and this is joined work
with my colleagues really recently molly
tao who's uh in the audience and santosh
kampala at georgia tech where i did my
postdoc previously so the talk will be
about this algorithm called the mirror
language algorithm so let me start by
describing what the problem we are
trying to solve is and then let me try
to give a motivation from a continuous
time perspective why
we are studying this kind of dynamics
and then i'll tell you about the main
result and the proof technique using
what's called the mean square analysis
okay
so this is the sampling problem where
the goal is we want to draw a sample
from a probability distribution let's
say mu and we assume that mu has a
density
of the form e to the minus f
on some domain x constrained in the
euclidean space
right so here we assume that the density
with respect to the labeling measure and
we are in the first order setting so we
assume that the the function f which is
the log density is differentiable and we
can access the gradient information
that's the goal is to draw to design an
algorithm to draw samples using this
information
and of course this has a very very nice
theory and connection
to optimization for example the the
space the problem of lock-on cave
sampling when the domain x and the
function f is convex has a lot to do
with context optimization and
furthermore as it's the theme of this
workshop of this whole program we can
view sampling as an optimization problem
in the space of probability distribution
so
most of that will be will be concerned
with the constraint setting when the
domain x is a proper subset of the
euclidean space but since this is the
beginning of the workshop let me try to
remind us all about what happens in the
unconstrained setting so the
unconstrained setting when we want to
draw a sample from the whole um from a
distribution new supported on the whole
euclidean space there are various
techniques we can do like for example in
the in in continuous time we can do we
can use what's called the language
dynamics which is the following
stochastic process which looks like
gradient flow for minimizing f plus
planium motion right and it is a
remarkable fact that these actually draw
a sample from the target distribution
either minus f asymptotically as t
equals infinity
and in discrete time we can try to
discretize this dynamics and that that
gives us what's called the unadjusted
launch of an algorithm but here it looks
like we are doing a gradient descent
step plus a gaussian noise of some step
size
right and there are um a lot of very
nice convergence analysis of these
algorithms when the um when this
function f the log density is convex
right and when we say convergence
analysis we have to specify what kind of
distance we are using and as a reminder
there are some really nice distances
right for example here's what's called
the positive stand distance which is the
we induced by optimal transport or we
can use some notion of divergences like
our divergence which is relative entropy
or chi square divergence and these two
are of course not symmetric so they're
not real distances but nevertheless we
can use them to measure convergence to
the target uh distribution new right
so for example in continuous time
uh designed to fund dynamics
so this has an optimization
interpretation as the gradient flow for
minimizing kl divergence for relative
entropy if we work in the space of
excuse me in the space of probability
distributions p over the euclidean space
using the metric given by the w2
distance rather this was the seminal
work by jordan kindler and otto from
1998
and and this interpretation gives us a
lot of very nice guarantees for this
continuous time dynamics for example
when the target is strongly locked on
cave then we know that this actually has
exponential contraction in first time
distance
and not just that we can actually relax
this condition and say that as long as
the target distribution satisfies some
inequalities some as a parametric
inequalities in such as the loxable
inequality of guangcare inequality then
we can actually show an exponential
convergence guarantee in either
divergence or chi square divergence
right so this says that in continuous
time we have a really good mixing time
bound with logarithmic dependence on the
error on one over epsilon
however in discrete time this question
is a lot more complicated right in
discrete time if we look at the
following unadjusted language algorithm
we know that this is a biased
discretization in the sense that in the
limit it converges to a distribution new
sub age which is different from your
actual target right
and the bias the distance between this
bias limit and the true target scales
with your step size right so um
when you when you translate that if this
gives you a mixing time bar with a
polynomial dependence on one over
epsilon instead of logarithmic so
um and we can make this pro formal and
we can show um there are now um really
good mixing sign bands for w-2 distance
under strong compact city for example by
the work of daloyan and durumu and
mullin and a lot of other people
and we can also do it under slightly
weaker condition for example a log
support inequality
one way to um
to address this issue is we can we can
also correct the bias with an acceptor
reject step and the resulting algorithm
called the metropolis adjusted launch of
an algorithm or mala
recovers the log one over epsilon
dependence but only in total variation
distance
and i think we'll see a lot of a few
talks about this this afternoon
okay so this is what happens in
uh in the unconstrained setting right so
now let's go to the constraint setting
where um
suppose the domain x is actually a
proper subset of the euclidean space
right either like a polytope or a sphere
and we want to draw a sample from a
distribution supported on this space
right for example the problem of uniform
sampling from a body tube is a very
important problem and that's still very
difficult
so um there are a lot of approaches to
do this one one basic approach is to say
that well um let's just run the useful
um language algorithm and whenever we go
outside let's just project back to the
space so that's what's called projected
language algorithm
and you can analyze this and uh there is
a mixing time bound for example by uh
and they work like blue back at all
but um in some sense this is not very uh
satisfactory because we really do not
want to go outside at all what happens
if we want to stay inside at all time
so another idea is
let's uh to use a metric that's in both
a metric on the space such that we
cannot go outside at all right so one
um one idea is uh one algorithm is
called the beacon walk and this is a
modification of the bulwark where we
draw samples from what's called the
beacon ellipsoid defined by the
hasher the log barrier function
so this is a similar idea to interior
point methods in optimization
and this has nice analysis using a
self-concordance barrier property so for
example uh by um
ravi and harina nayanan it's just that
um when we want to draw a uniform sample
from a polytope in d dimension with m
facets
it has a complexity proportional to n
times d and recently um
it's been improved
using motion of weight and barrier
function and without strong
self-confidence uh it actually has
faster
mixing time bound another d squared so
this is a very very nice um theory and
a related approach to this is uh what's
called the mirror range of an algorithm
which is what we study in this algorithm
so here we also use a barrier function
but we use the gradient of a sort of
mirror map
uh to map it to the dual space
and then we do the updates in the dual
space we do a long different algorithm
or some other update and then we map it
back to the previous space so this is
similar to what's called mirror descent
in optimization right so this algorithm
was proposed in this paper by zhang at
code last year
and
see also there was also an earlier
little approach using a slightly
different dynamics by ciao that appeared
a few years earlier
okay so what is what is this algorithm
uh the algorithm looks like the
following so
um here we want to draw a sample from
distribution of the form e to the minus
f and the object looks like um we apply
um we choose
phi which is called a legendre function
and we uh we use the gradient to map the
domain x to the dual space and then we
do the the launch of an update in the
dual space except that the hessian of
your phi also appears as the covariance
in the gaussian noise right
and in some sense this this is the the
sampling analog of mirror descent
because you can also write this in a
form that's more reminiscent to mirror
the sense where you're saying that your
next point is obtained by minimizing
some
linear function right this is just a
constant vector
plus the bracket divergence generated by
your function phi
so without this additional randomness
this becomes the mirror descent
algorithm it turns out that if you add
this gaussian noise with this covariance
then this gives you a sampling algorithm
and you can ask why why do you need to
add this where does this come from
and it's also that um where it comes
from one way to see it is that this
comes from this pricing what's called
the mirror launcher fun dynamics in
continuous time which is the following
stochastic differential equation in
terms of y which is the gradient of phi
of x
so this looks somewhat nicer because now
we don't we don't have the step size
but then you can still ask why is this
the right dynamics to use for sampling
right where does it come from
so let me try to give a very like high
level overview of
what happens in continuous time and a
lot of this was also covered in the
bootcamp tutorial a few weeks ago so let
me try to
uh just go
quickly
so um so what happens here is that we
are in the in the metric setting where
we work with the convex subset of
euclidean space but we treat we treat it
as a manifold okay so at every point x
we endure it with a metric g
uh written as a positive definite matrix
uh g of x and we use that to define the
notion of local inner product at each
tangent space right so at the point x
you have this tangent space and you
measure the inner product between two
vectors u and v
by multiplying it by this g matrix right
and the euclidean setting you need
matrix the case when g is the identity
matrix but you can put a lot of other g
right for example a nice case is the
hessian metric when g is the hessian of
a convex function 5.
so
if we have this setting what do we do
for optimization for example if we want
to minimize a function f
then we can run the following romanian
gradient flow where
the curve x follows this differential
equation where here this gradient of f
is the r2 vector of gradient of partial
derivatives and then we multiply it by
the inverse metric g
to turn it into a proper remaining
tangent vector right so
formally um
the vector partial derivative is a
differential in the cotangent space and
then you need to make it back to the
tangent space by this inverse metric
but as a pode in in
in rd this is what remaining ingredient
flow looks like right
and and then this gives you a lot of
nice information for example you can say
that if f is strongly convex in the
geodesic sense meaning it's something
conflicts along two dev6 defined by your
method g then this is an exponentially
contracting
curve
and inside you can also relax that for
example if the function f plus files was
called the gradient domination condition
or this was called the bl inequality
usually but now with respect to the
metric g right so this definition um
these norms of x here
is using this definition where you have
this metric g here
but if you have this inequality then you
can show that the function value
decreases exponentially fast
along your uh gradient flow so this is
for any g
and then it's inside that a nice case is
when we when we have a hessian metric
and then this is what's called a natural
gradient flow usually in the literature
and and you can try to um discretize
this when you discretize this you get
what's called the natural gradient
descent but it looks like you're doing
creating the sand except that you also
multiply by this inverse hessian the
inverse metric
so this was um studied by amari for
example
but one of the issue is that this
algorithm requires hessian information
right
so instead what we can do is let's look
at this dynamics in the dual space
right so
in the dual space meaning that we apply
this gradient of phi which we call the
mirror map to map the domain x to the to
the dual space y
so anything we can do in the primal
space we can do the dual space right if
i have a function f here i can push it
forward uh to get a function f tilde
here by saying that my f tilde is just f
composed with the inverse map
right so that if i map x to y
then my function value f of x gets
mapped to the function value of still
delta y right and similarly what's
really nice in this setup is that the
metric the hessian metric defined by phi
on this space
gets pushed forward
uh to hessian metric here which is
induced by the dual function phi star
right and that happens that works
because we are mapping by this mirror
map so that is there is a very nice um
duality condition here
and then in the startup in the dual
space uh natural gradient flow becomes
for mirror flow
um
and this mirror flow is also the natural
gradient flow for minimizing we push
this push forward function under this
push forward metric
and then dispersing this gives us the
mirror design algorithm optimization and
the advantage is that now there is no
hessian involved this one involves the
gradient
right
so this is what happens for
optimization now let's uh let's see what
happens for sampling we want to like
look at um what are all these things
when we want to do sample samplings of
optimization
let's go back to our constraint sampling
problem where we want to to sample from
some domain
and we impose some metric g on the space
right
so what what what kind of dynamics
should we use
so the analog of remaining brain flow is
the following thing called remaining
elemental fund dynamics so this looks
like
um oneself and dynamics with some drift
and some
brownian motion
where as before we multiply the gradient
by the inverse metric but then the
inverse metric also comes up in the
covariance of the branding motion
as well as in this correction term in
the derivative the divergence of the
inverse metric
so this was um this has been studied a
lot previously classically like for
example in this reference
and you can see that in the euclidean
case
you don't have this term here and this
divergence becomes zero so this gives us
back to your bunch of fun dynamics but
in general you have this covariance and
this correction term and these are there
so that uh overall this dynamics has the
same has correct the correct stationary
distribution which is either means f
where f is what whatever appears here
right
um and you can ask like how do you check
something like that one way to say it is
to to say that if x follows dynamics
follow um from this sde
then the density row involves following
a pde which is called a focal plane
equation and the form looks like the
following where the the inverse metric
um your covariance here just appears
here just multiplying the gradients of
the log density
and then from this you can see that when
rho is equal to nu
the right hand side becomes zero so mu
is a stationary solution right
and whatever the optimization
interpretation still works that this is
also the gradient flow for minimizing k
or divergence but not using the first
star metric generated by this matrix g
on the on the base base right
and then all the conclusion before about
exponential convergence rate and so
parametry we can also say when
everything is defined with respect to
this matrix g right
okay so this is the general structure
and now let's ask what happens in the
hessian
case
so suppose we use a hessian metric when
g is the hessian of some context
function phi
and then uh this gives us what's called
the mirror launcher fund dynamics where
uh
everything here was g before and we just
replace it by this inversion
right so this is nice but it still looks
somewhat complicated because uh because
of this thermosphere right this is the
divergence of the inverse hash chance it
looks complicated
but then um recalling what we did after
optimization when we when we mapped the
dual space mirror flow becomes really
nice here we can do the same trick that
in the dual space let's map it from x to
y
via this mirror map and it turns out
that um this middle arrangement dynamics
becomes something that's much simpler
but because the drift term simplifies
just one term
there is no inverse hession involved
there is no divergence involved
basically because everything cancels out
you do the calculation
and here the
um
the hessian of phi
is replaced by the hessian of phi star
and this is because the metric uh this
hedge metric is pushed forward to this
hesometric of five star by the middleman
right
and then um
um describing this uh dynamics gives us
the mirror range of an algorithm
so um so this was the dynamics that was
studied by uh beijing at all and also a
lot of work by uh chewie and philip
and um and co-authors where um the study
that this dynamics has very nice
properties in continuous time and so for
example if the target distribution the
the target in the primal space is e to
the minus f and then the target in the
dual space is just a push forward of
that either minus f by the mirror map
and then
we can say that if the target satisfies
either lobsabol left or one array with
respect to the hessian metric so what's
called the mirror card inequality in in
the in the paper then we can conclude an
exponential convergence in k of
divergence of chi square divergence
right
um okay so
let's see
okay so this is not the topic of this
stuff maybe i won't spend too much time
here but a very very nice uh property
happens when you choose phi to be equal
to f
right because then you can see that the
green of f cancels out with the gradient
of f star
and that's what uh gives us what's
called the newton launcher fund
dynamics i was studied by this paper by
sinho and philippine authors and a
remarkable property of these dynamics is
that the boundary inequality of your
distribution is a minus f with respect
to its own hessian metric is always true
and that's because you can um you can
show that it's equivalent to what's
called the brass complete inequality
which is a classical inequality that
holds for any logo function f
sorry
or any strictly complex f right so this
says that along this dynamics along this
euthanasia dynamics the chi squared
level just converges exponentially fast
for any local given you with a uniform
rate right
and interestingly this this dynamics in
in fact also appeared in an earlier work
by fatih from a different perspective
from a spine kernel perspective
um okay and
um maybe let me escape this one but in
optimization something this is what um
the corresponding property that happens
okay so now let's go back to discrete
time so
hopefully that gave us a brief overview
of
why we get about the dynamics of the
study but now let's look at uh what we
can say in the actual discrete time
algorithm so again this is the middle
range of an algorithm this was a first
proposed and studied by zhang and all as
a discretization of the mirror and
dynamics which we just saw
and what they showed uh in the paper is
that
they show that that the interest of this
algorithm have a convergence
has a bias convergence where the bias is
non-vanishing and is meaning that the
bias does not go to zero
if we scale the step size to zero
so
a bit more concretely
so they assume some set of conditions
one of them is the following property
called modified self-concurrence so this
is an assumption on the choice of the
general function phi so the assumption
is that the square root of as a matrix
the square of matrix of this hessian
is slip sheets in the hilbert schmidt
norm
with some parameter alpha
and essentially
what what they show is that the bias of
the algorithm scales as something that
goes to zero step size plus an
asymptotic term that depends on the
dimension and alpha this parameter here
but there is no step size here right so
um as you scale the step size to zero
you still get this term so what this
means is that um
what they show is that the interest of
the algorithm converts to a ball around
the minimizer but we're not sure yet if
it actually contributes to the um
to the solution to the minus f oh yes
that's the question um
what is the one
are these sharp bonds uh um in some
sense no so part of the question here is
that so they conjecture that this this
bias uh this non-finishing bias is
unavoidable uh um essentially because we
are describing something with a
multiplicative noise
and so what we show is that in fact with
a slightly more refined analysis we can
remove this um
this bias and then we get a term that
looks like that
um but yeah but so so this observation
and this conjecture modified the
question of um
do we need either a better algorithm
maybe we need a more sophisticated
discrimination of this um
of the dynamics or can we just analyze
this in a in a better way right so on
the on the front of a better algorithm
there were a few
follow-up works including an alternative
physicalization by uh kwang jun and
sinho chewie where
we apply
this two-step process where we take a
gradient step in the dual space that
looks like mirror descent and then we
solve the turning motion part exactly a
brand new motion part with this um
[Music]
this running motion but with this
changing covariance right
and what they show is that if you
analyze this algorithm you can show a
vanishing bias with a very very nice
analysis using nice conditions such as
self-importance and using um convex
optimization um tools more closely
however this requires uh solving this uh
dynamics which may be difficult uh
for general phi right
so um okay with that with that setup
what we showed the following we studied
the basic algorithm of mirror langible
algorithm the same algorithm the
proposed previously and we we showed
that in fact it has
a convergent a bias convergence with a
vanishing bias meaning that the bias
goes to zero with step size and moreover
we only use a subset of the assumptions
in the original paper
and what what i was showing in the rest
of this talk is that a proof technique
using what's called the mean square
analysis framework
and in fact we will apply that to the
dual space remember that this is the the
primal form of the middle range of an
algorithm if we look at the dual
variable y
by the middle map then it looks a little
bit simpler
so in the y space it looks like we are
doing um
we are taking a step along this
direction with a with a gaussian noise
with this covariance right
okay
so more
more precisely so here are the
assumptions that we need
so we assume the following we assume
that
the choice of the general function phi
satisfies modified cell concurrence
which means the the square root
of the hessian is slip sheets in the
hilbert schmidt node
with parameter square root alpha
and
we also assume that the function f is
smooth with respect to phi which means
that the gradient
the difference of the gradient of f is
borrowed above by the difference of the
gradient of phi
and moreover it is strongly convex with
respect to phi
which is the following
and you can you can look at the name and
see that when phi in the euclidean case
when finds a quadratic function this
becomes as the usual smoothness
condition this becomes the strong
complexity condition right and when the
first quadratic this becomes um
this is trivial because this um uh
difference on the zero or five zero
right but for general phi um this alpha
can be nonzero
um so in the paperback jungle they also
assume some other conditions which we
don't need so these are the three
conditions we
use and our result
okay so before that
so we can also translate these
conditions in the dual space right so in
the dual space in terms of y which is um
the middle map of x let's define this
matrix a of y which is the square root
inverse session of phi star and this
vector g of y which is the region of f
composed with green phi star and you can
see that this
property translated the property that
the matrix a is slip sheets um
in in the in the usual sense right
and this f being m smooth with respect
to phi
says that this vector g is also limited
strong complexity with respect to phi
says that this vector g is monotone
in the useful sense so in the dual space
all these conditions become the useful
nice conditions that we that we have
previously
and here's the main result so assume
uh distribute a182a3 and the main the
main important requirement is that uh
the self-confidence parameter alpha is
bounded above by m over 2 where m is
that's alpha is the parameter here in
the self-conformance modifical
concordance and little m is the strong
convexity constant
so we
we require that
this alpha
does not go too large it has to be less
than m over two here
and
there is a choice of maximum step size
such that the the algorithm mirrorless
of an algorithm has the following bias
convergence currency in the dual space
in the y variable that after k
iterations
uh your w2 distance between your iterate
and
the target right so new is a target in
the primal space and then we push it
forward by the middle map to get this
target into a space
so here the v2 distance
um
is followed by the following there is
one term that goes to zero with uh with
k with iteration and then there is
another term that scales with the square
root step size so this is the biased
term
and moreover this uh this constant c
is also explicit it's on the order of
square root dimension
uh yes question the question is less
than m over two could you just always
make that one by scaling up f
um
right so the question is uh does
condition alpha last and m one pursuit
does it can you always make it work by
scaling up f uh i think i think so yes
right so um if you just phi it has some
alpha and then um
if if your m doesn't work here you can
scale f so that uh that's nicer
yes right so so this condition says that
we may not be able to sample from either
minus f but we can sample from either
minus f over some constant
yeah
um
so this is in the dual space and you can
see that in the primal space it has the
same guarantee because everything just
gets mapped by the this mirror map right
but notice that here this is not just
guarantee that there will be two
distance in the euclidean match right
not
not using the hessian metric and it's
the two distance here is with respect to
this induced mirror map so this is the
same distance that they use in the
original paper by jung at all right
but in particular this shows that the
bias actually scales with square root of
d times h so there is no there is none
of these
asymptotic non-vanishing bias
um and then as a corollary as usual
right so what if you want to make this
class an epsilon you can set both of
these to be less than epsilon and that
gives you a mixing time bound right so
this says that
if we want to get um w2 distance has an
epsilon then we can run this algorithm
but the step size h scales with epsilon
square
right and then we need to run it for
some iterations that scales with
essentially one over the contraction
factor times um step size right so step
size gives us one over return square so
then this gives us this missing time
bound um on this other dimension of
reference square assuming that all the
other parameters m and big m and so on
are dimension three for now
um so if you compare this with ula in
the unconstrained euclidean setting
right so you can show for example a
typical
result is to say that under smoothness
and strong convexity the bias scales as
dimension times h right so then the
missing time bound is
d over epsilon
and a more recently thought by um leo r
shows that if you also have a third
order smoothness condition then you can
improve this dimension to be smaller
dimension and then that gives us missing
time bound to square root d over epsilon
but instead for for this middle range of
an algorithm the bias uh scales as well
as step size right and that's what gives
us this one for epsilon square
dependence and this is essentially
because we are discretizing an ste with
what's called multiplicative noise with
changing of variance so
we lose an order
um
okay so so that was the result and then
for the rest of the talk i'll try to
describe the proof technique using mean
squared analysis uh framework
before you go there can i ask a good
question yes how do you when you
specialize this to phi equals f uh what
does the so i know that a2 and a3 are
basically free with m equals one but uh
yeah what does they want what does it
say
yeah yeah no very good question so the
question is what happens when phi is
equal to f one in the newton case so
these are always true with m equal to
one uh here it just says that your f
satisfies this condition that the
hessian of the
um
square root
infrastructure function is slip sheets
so
it's a
i'll have an example later so in one
dimension this is equivalent to saying
that phi is self-concurrence in the
classical sense but in higher dimension
this is not the same so this condition
um
so part of our discussion in the end
will be that this condition is sometimes
not ideal because this is not a finite
variance for example whereas the
classical soft concurrence condition is
very nice it's of an invariant and so on
so we would like to replace this
condition by something that's more
natural but yeah but for general f this
is not a frequency you have to check
this
um
okay
sorry how much time do i have
four or five minutes okay um maybe let
me
let me not go into the detail of the
mean square analysis but uh but my
colleague monitor is here and and uh
happy to chat up more but the very high
level idea is that uh mean square
analysis is a very general powerful
framework for burning the error between
a discretization
algorithm and a continuous time process
right so
maybe let me show you the
before that
so uh so classically in the classical
setting we can um so this is a very
classical technique from uh
analysis and physics and so on but
classically we can only show bounds up
until some constant iteration
but it turns out that if we assume that
in continuous time the process is
contracting then we can control the
error so that we can conclude
the bound for all time so we get a
global bound on the error between the
algorithm and the process
so
this was analyzed and proposed by this
paper by leonardo the stretching leader
danny wu mastermind
doctor at new rips a few years ago but
for this talk and our work we will use a
morrison crystal extension by
liat all
probably willingly hong youngja and
moritza
which has a slightly weaker requirements
on the error that allows us to apply
this for the algorithm
so um
let me skip the setup but um
the assumption is the following that in
continuous time we assume the process is
contracting and if you take any two
synchronous solution and you let them
run they have to convert exponentially
fast
and furthermore the diffusion has the
following what's called division bound
that in short time they cannot actually
deviate too much and then we also have
condition on the algorithm that if i
give you a discrete time algorithm there
is a notion of what's called local weak
error and local strong error and this
balance the difference between if you
start at the same point and you let a
diffusion process run and you let an
algorithm run you want to bound the
error between these two points right the
logarithmic error is error in in the
expectation and the local strong error
is error in the r2 norm
um so previously the previous work
these constants t1 and b2 are zero but
now in this more recent work that we use
we can have the following bigger
condition
so
then so here are the assumptions for the
mean square analysis that um the
important part is that the consistent
process is contracting and your
description algorithm has bounded error
orders
now the conclusion is that
um there is a maximum step size such
that for all time you can bound the
error between your discrete time
algorithm and your continuous time
solution
and the bound does not depend on k the
bound scales of your step size to what's
called the strong error order management
half
um sorry i'm just giving a lot of detail
here because uh
just to give you the
idea and we can compute the constants
explicitly
so um
yeah and and for the proof uh uh um you
can show it satisfies the following
construction the uh recursion
but let me show you how we apply this to
our algorithm right so for our algorithm
remember this is the uh in continuous
time the algorithm comes from the mirror
launcher fun
dynamics and we have the following three
assumptions
and what we will what we show
essentially is that these three
assumptions imply that all the
assumptions in the minimum analysis
framework are satisfied and then we can
conclude the mixing time bound
all right so um
so please check out the paper for the
detail but we show that the assumption
of lesson m over 2
implies that the dynamics is contracting
with this rate minus two alpha right and
we can check the division bound also
let me skip the
proof
and moreover we can check that the
discrete time algorithm has the
following error orders of p1 is three
half and p2 is one
right
and we can also track the constants
explicitly
so then
the proof of the main result is to say
that well all those conditions actually
implied that we satisfied the mean
square analysis assumptions
and then we can conclude the following
currency which is our main result all
right
so uh yeah so please check out the paper
if you're interested or i'm happy to
talk to
um
and let me let me finish by just
mentioning some
discussion about this result
so this is what we show that we show
this topic two mixing time bound has
this bias which implies the following um
mixing time bound
but um
here are some questions so one is that
everything right now is in the euclidean
metric we would like to have something
in the hessian metric right
or
in other distances in other measures
um the conditions right now uh assume
this relative smoothness and some
complexity so they do not work for
example for sampling from uniform or
gaussian if we use a log barrier
function essentially because for this
barrier function you want the hash and
equal to infinity on the boundary so you
want your so this implies your f also
has to go to infinity on the boundary
right so can we weaken this assumption
and then a real question is this notion
of modified self-concurrence in one
dimension is the same as the classical
notion of cell concordance but in higher
dimension it's not the same so so here's
an example that you can show that for
the poly two or the log barrier function
so remember that this satisfies cell
concordance with parameters two right
classically and then it's inside if you
do the calculation the modified
self-conformance parameter of this
function can be as bad as one over the
square
smaller singular value of a
your constraint matrix
and you can make this as better as you
want so even in two dimension
so here's an example you look at this
polyhedron so this intersection of two
half spaces
you can you can choose explicit points
and you can compute this ratio and you
can achieve this bound one over epsilon
squared
so you can make this to infinity
right so we would like to have something
with a more natural self-concurrence
condition
and finally um the current technique
uses um continuous time contraction as
part of the assumption so can we weaken
that can we have an analysis where the
consistent process is just converging
not contracting and so we know how to do
this for example for ula but can we do
it with uh with this multiplicative
noise
okay so thank you so much that was um
our result and um please check out this
display print and let us know if you
have any more questions thank you
just a question about the mirror maps is
it easy to actually find those
is it easy to find those part of the
assumption is that you have to be able
uh to compute this
you want to advise that you can compute
this pretty easily and this inverse
map easily so for some nice functions
like um entropy and so on you can do
that but
but in general the choice is that you
also have to satisfy all these
conditions right
so for now the result is still somewhat
restricted
yes so
so when you try to use the basic
mla
i'm still a little confused why it's
biased when you let h go to zero so
basically you are saying when you let h
go to zero it will not converge to a
continuous limit
uh it will it will the dynamics itself
will right so the
uh in continuous time
it comes from this neuron to fund
dynamics
but
part of the issue was that um
the previous
previous work
shows that um
in terms of the
w2 bound that is a biased skills with
step size plus this uh something that
does not go to zero and the question was
that um was this an artifact of the
analysis or was this inherent to the
algorithm essentially because we are
discretizing something without changing
covariance
for ula when this was a constant we did
not have this
term also in the euclidean case when phi
is quadratic right so alpha is zero so
then this term disappears so this
requires the correct result for ula but
not for mla and but yeah
yeah and part of our contribution is to
say that this really was an artifact and
we can do
a modified analysis
one more question and then we'll all go
out for a break
yeah so i have one question so you uh so
does the condition alpha less than m
over two is it because uh it's needed
because is it because
of numerical side or the analytic side
about the
whether it's about the convergence of
the continuous time dynamics or about
the numerical error yeah that is the
question is uh this this constraint on m
and alpha so right now it's needed in
the in the calculation because um
um i i skipped this this line earlier
but if you have choose a synchronous
solution and you compute the difference
between their l2 norm uh
the difference of the square covariance
happens here so here you can see why
modified sub-components is is a natural
condition to use
and the term that comes out the constant
is m minus alpha
so that's the condition but you can also
see that um
in general we need some bound alpha on
the lip sheets concern of this one to
make sure the sd converges right so you
can look at for example the geometric
dominant motion which is the following
sde you can check that there is a
threshold that if alpha is above one um
this traverses when alpha is below one
it converges to zero so there is there
is a different behavior depending on the
lip stiffness of this covariance
but yeah but it's not clear
if we can relax this i really would like
to
thank you so much sure
okay so
let's continue the discussion with some
caffeine and sugar outside
and let's first thank andre again for
the great talk
[Applause]
and
we'll be back at 11 30.
um